14 січня Росія вкотре завдала масованого ракетного удару по критичній та цивільній інфраструктурі України
різними типами крилатих та авіаційних ракет.
25 із 38-ми знищила українська ППО.
Серед тих, які не вдалося перехопити, - крилаті ракети Х-22.
Одна з них влучила у житловий будинок у Дніпрі з великою кількістю жертв серед мирних мешканців.
За словами командування Повітряних сил ЗСУ, українська ППО не здатна збивати такий тип ракет -
для цього потрібні сучасні зенітні ракетні комплекси на кшталт Patriot чи SAMP-T.
Також Київщину РФ атакувала новими ракетами із ЗРК С-400,
для виявлення і перехоплення яких ЗСУ поки теж не мають ефективних засобів.
Оглядачі не виключають, що Росія вдалася до такої тактики,
бо Україна навчилася ефективно збивати інші типи ворожих ракет
та успішно відбивати атаки дронів-камікадзе.
Зокрема, у новорічну ніч українські сили ППО збили 100% випущених Росією безпілотників: 45 із 45-ти,
та 39 - у ніч із 1-го на 2-ге січня.
Загалом же з вересня, від початку застосування іранських "шахедів",
українська ППО знищила понад 540 ворожих дронів.
Щоправда, для цього Україна докладає багато зусиль і витрачає чимало коштів.
Баражуючий боєприпас, яким є Shahed-136, скажімо, якщо беремо його,
це небезпечна зброя, це високоточна зброя, це далекобійна зброя,
яка летить на великі дистанції, яка вражає ціль точно, яка летить за прокладеним маршрутом,
який прокладають з метою подолати нашу систему протиповітряної оборони.
Власне, летить вона точно в ціль.
Як знаєте, їх застосовують групами, що ускладнює роботу наших засобів протиповітряної оборони по них.
Росія використовує дрони-камікадзе, щоб бити по мирних містах
і руйнувати критичну цивільну інфраструктуру України.
Противник постійно змінює тактику: запускає безпілотники вночі,
пускає їх групами за різними маршрутами чи вздовж течії Дніпра.
Тому, щоб збити ворожі цілі, Україна використовує цілий комплекс засобів протиповітряної оборони,
розповів DW речник командування Повітряних Сил ЗСУ.
То чим же Україна збиває іранські дрони-камікадзе?
Найчастіше і найефективніше дрони-камікадзе збивають зенітно-ракетними комплексами.
Вони здатні виявити і знищити ціль, яка летить уночі.
Хоча раніше вдень проти цих безпілотників застосовували й зенітні гармати та крупнокаліберну стрілецьку зброю,
наприклад крупнокаліберні кулемети.
Зенітні ракетні комплекси, які є в нас на озброєнні, основа наших ЗРВ (зенітно-ракетних військ) - це Бук-М1, С-300.
Ними ефективно знищуються. Найефективніше збивають, зрозуміло, їх засоби,
які мають радіолокаційні системи, які мають радіолокаційні засоби,
мається на увазі, які захоплюють ціль і знищують їх в цьому режимі.
При цьому дещо застарілі радянські системи, такі як Бук-М1, С-300 та С-125
поступово доповнюють західними, набагато ефективнішими комплексами:
німецькими IRIS-T та норвезькими NASAMS.
Вони, за словами Юрія Ігната, посилюють українську оборону
і дають кращий результат у збитті повітряних цілей.
IRIS-T - це суто німецький комплекс. Поки що лише одна установка у складі однієї батареї.
Найближчим часом вже і Олаф Шольц обіцяв уже решту установок доправити в Україну,
що допоможе наростити спроможності цієї батареї,
яка буде охоплювати значно більший повітряний простір і захищати нашу державу,
нашу критичну інфраструктуру та інші об’єкти.
NASAMS - це норвезький комплекс, на якому озброєні американські ракети AIM-120 AMRAAM.
Саме ці комплекси надані Сполученими Штатами Америки Україні.
Саме ці комплекси, деякі з них, захищають небо столиці.
Була успішна робота зокрема і в новорічну ніч NASAMS.
Це дві батареї, вони теж не в повному складі.
Хотілося б, щоб ця батарея була доповнена, кожна з них, більшою кількістю саме пускових установок.
Ті всі комплекси, які маємо сьогодні на озброєнні, IRIS, NASAMS та будемо мати Patriot -
це найкраще є, що є сьогодні у світі.
Хотілося б ще і SAMP/T - французько-італійський комплекс,
який міг би теж доповнити і теж, як і Patriot, може збивати і балістичні цілі.
При цьому важливо ще й постійно поповнювати боєприпаси
до вже доставлених сучасних систем протиповітряної оборони.
У тих зонах, які не перекриті засобами протиповітряної оборони, піднімають винищувальну авіацію.
Військові льотчики неодноразово ефективно протистояли одразу кільком "шахедам".
Наприклад, пілот з позивним "Карая" збив 5 ворожих дронів-камікадзе над Вінницею.
Останнім часом ефективність довели мобільні вогневі групи, які мають на озброєнні і зенітні гармати,
і ПЗРК, тобто переносні зенітно-ракетні комплекси – "Стінгер", І-2 та інші.
У них є великий досвід і ціла команда, яка працює над тим, щоб виявити, захопити і знищити ціль.
Її треба виявити. По-перше, є системи зв’язку, оповіщення, є візуальні пости спостереження,
які дозволяють дуже швидко визначати, координувати дії і передавати цю інформацію
безпосередньо оператору ПЗРК, який може здійснювати уже стрільбу більш ефективно.
Треба розуміти, що прожектором треба його спіймати, по-перше, той "шахед", скажімо так.
По-друге, вести його, супроводжувати, щоб він був у тому струмені світла.
І, знову ж таки, інша людина, яка сидить за крупнокаліберним кулеметом чи за зеніткою,
має теж вправно стріляти на випередження, по корпусу треба вміло робити коректування балістичне.
Тому не все так просто, але наші хлопці справляються.
Також застосовуються, я вже назвав, самохідні зенітні установки:
"Гепард", працює, зрозуміло, що ППО Сухопутних військ, такі комплекси як "Оса" -
це зенітно-ракетний комплекс малого радіусу дії.
Поряд з ним уже працює французький "Кроталь" (Crotale), який є теж надзвичайно ефективним
у збитті цих повітряних цілей.
Наші теж такі як "Шилка", "Тунгуска" є.
Зрозуміло, що західні зразки набагато ефективніші у виявленні та знищенні цих БПЛА.
На певних ділянках фронту застосовують засоби радіоелектронної боротьби,
які можуть знешкоджувати ворожі дрони.
Утім, покрити і заглушити повністю настільки велику за протяжністю лінію фронту, як в Україні, неможливо.
Крім того, "шахеди" використовують кілька систем GPS-навігації,
тому не завжди вдається обійти усі одразу.
Тоді дрони врешті-решт потрібно збивати.
Наразі на боротьбу з іранськими дронами Україна витрачає в рази більше грошей,
ніж коштують самі ворожі БПЛА.
Це визначили аналітики спільноти "Мольфар", які провели дослідження на основі відкритих джерел
і з'ясували, скільки дронів-камікадзе збили українські військові,
яким видом зброї і скільки це коштувало Україні.
От, наприклад, є ППО С-300. Там один залп коштує 145 тисяч доларів.
Є ручний гранатомет ПЗРК "Ігла" - там один постріл коштує 60-80 тисяч доларів,
тому що він, по суті, одноразовий, і за рахунок цього така ціна.
Зараз ми перейдемо до такого, напевно, найбільш коштовного пострілу - батарея ППО NASAMS.
Там один постріл може коштувати від 500 тисяч до 3 мільйонів залежно від того, скільки випускається ракет.
Але з того, що я бачу, NASAMS використовують, коли об’єкт вже підлітає дуже близько до міста умовно
чи до якоїсь критичної інфраструктури.
Є також ППО, яке передала Німеччина, IRIS-T.
Там, в принципі, ціна схожа на NASAMS - близько 400 тисяч доларів.
Один постріл з американського "Стінгера" коштує 40 тисяч доларів,
а виліт винищувача "Міг-29" може коштувати до 700 тисяч доларів.
За даними аналітиків, лише у жовтні Україна збила 161 "шахед" вартістю приблизно 3,22 мільйона доларів.
А витратила на це від 12 до 18 мільйонів доларів.
Якщо ми дивимося на жовтень, то тоді в деяких випадках там умовно ми витрачали у 100 разів більше,
ніж коштує іранський дрон. Тому що він там умовно коштує 20-40 тисяч доларів,
а один вистріл з ППО залежно від типу може коштувати і пів мільйона доларів чи 300 тисяч.
Далі, коли ми зробили апдейт через місяць, у листопаді,
там ми вийшли вже на оцінку ефективності у 6-7 разів по ціні.
Тобто умовно за місяць Україна дуже сильно прогресує,
і якщо раніше ми збивали чисто через ППО, то тоді з’явилися мобільні групи
з автоматами і ручними гранатометами, почали використовувати літаки,
які злітали і збивали одразу декілька дронів.
У командуванні Повітряних сил кажуть, що недоцільно порівнювати витрати на збиття дронів-камікадзе дорогими ракетами,
бо потенційні збитки, завдані ними інфраструктурі значно вищі,
а життя людей взагалі не можна виміряти грошима.
Щоб захистити населення та інфраструктуру, ЗСУ готові використовувати усі можливі засоби.
Якби ж у нас було достатньо більш дешевих засобів,
більш раціонально використовувати нашу систему ППО, безумовно, ми б це робили.
Але на даний час виходимо з того, що ми маємо, очікуємо від наших партнерів інших систем,
зокрема ППО Сухопутних військ, ті ж самі "Гепарди" якби були у великій кількості,
щоб їх можна було розставити і захистити кожен наш об’єкт критичної інфраструктури
чи напрямки відповідні, тоді буде більш ефективно.
Скільки ми витрачаємо на це збиття - це не так важливо,
тому що ми по факту збиваємо і захищаємо життя людей, і це найважливіше.
Другий основний пункт, що ефективність росте з кожним місяцем.
Наприклад, от одна електропідстанція коштує близько 30 мільйонів.
І якщо ми дивимося ціну збиття одного дрона там навіть 200-300 тисяч доларів, то це дуже ефективно.
Тому я вважаю, що в цілому Україна досить ефективно бореться з дронами
і взагалі гарний показник ППО - це 50% збиття,
а в цьому випадку ми збиваємо майже 90% за останніми даними, і цей показник ще дедалі прогресує.
Західні військові експерти також вражені тим,
як Україна навчилася ефективно збивати ворожі безпілотники.
У мене враження, що українська протиповітряна оборона стає дедалі кращою.
І ми також побачили, що Україна змогла збити майже 100% безпілотників, які летіли.
Тож я думаю, що є ознаки дуже значного покращення.
Ми загалом дуже вражені українським опором і українською обороною проти усіх видів загроз.
А коли йдеться про ракети та безпілотники, які хвилями направляють на українські міста,
ми багато чого вчимося з того, як українці захищають свої міста та своїх людей.
Та щоб ефективність цієї боротьби ставала вищою,
Україні потрібно постачати більше дешевших систем протиповітряної оборони, вказує військовий експерт.
Ми бачили, як українські бійці збивали безпілотники з кулеметів,
ми бачили, як використовуються авіаційні ракети,
тому все, що є, потрібно використовувати проти цих безпілотників.
Але в довгостроковій перспективі, якщо Росія надсилає сотні й тисячі цих безпілотників,
використання дуже дорогих зенітних ракет не буде ефективним.
Тому для боротьби з цими безпілотниками слід використовувати електронні перешкоди,
глушилки та інші більш дешеві інструменти.
Ракетний тероризм Росії триває.
Україна готується до чергових ударів.
Небезпеку усвідомлюють і на Заході.
Зокрема США нещодавно заявили, що закуплять для України 14 антидронових систем Vampire.
Ці установки допоможуть відстежувати і збивати ворожі безпілотники
та захищатися від наземних загроз противника.
А встановити їх можна на звичайні цивільні пікапи.